oh hi everybody I am so excited this is
an interview I've been wanting to do
since the moment I started at ET almost
six years ago we've got Tommy Wiseau
we've got Greg Sestero in studio hey
guys are you doing they are iconic I'm
sure you know them from the room at the
disaster artist based on their lives
based on your book and then now you guys
have best friends coming out as well
ever since the room Tommy hasn't really
been captured the way I feel like he
could deliver and so I thought you know
this could be my chance to return the
favor
to make a film and put Tommy in a role
where he could shine and 15 years later
make a film I was really excited and it
was really great to work with him this
time around and really try to make
something different because because the
room you can't recapture the magic of
the room I mean it's it's something
that's so special for what it is and I
really thought it would be great if
Tommy and I tried to take on a new
challenge and make you know make like a
modern strange Hitchcock film and just
try to you know really try to make
something right because I'm sure people
ask you all the time are you gonna do a
sequel a prequel or something else like
a room to what do you say with people
you know we actually want to do the room
on Broadway not off-broadway all brother
when I put the musical that's my my
dream actually to do it be very very
close to actually work on that but we
already did the the room on the stage
and the AFI in Washington that was the
way five years ago right for you yeah
sounds like that but what people asked
me respond to your question you know I
always say you know you never know what
will happen I wanted to actually 3ds but
then I changed my mind because now I'm
working in different projects mm-hmm but
eventually we do something something
with the room
well bestfriends is coming out March
30th volume one right so this is split
into two at this point so much good
material so what is it about Tommy plays
a mortician who collects something
that's very strange and I play at this
homeless drifter we have we have this
encounter and we come up with this
business
that's underground that ends up making a
good amount of money and once we get
into that problems start to arise so I
was inspired by Nightcrawler and drive
and kind of you know those those classic
noir films Double Indemnity so it's a
very strange film but I think it I think
its original and I think we I think we
did something well I think Tommy is
really fantastic in the film I really
thank the people that have seen it are
are really taken back by just like how
interesting years I would say you know
rolled out suits him and yeah they said
because I'm sure a lot of people just
want to see you guys on screen together
again how was it similar to the room is
it is it just a completely different
thing I felt also different a lot of
people have this assumption that this
similar to the not at all so if you look
at the the best friends and you look at
the room total different movie I told
him I don't know if you remember right
Greg I told you I said nothing from the
room yeah because to me the room I'm you
know I love the room for what it is but
that was Neil plants I interrupt you but
that was your plan right to do
everything original yeah because I think
the fandom of the room is something that
I admire you know screen up for 15 years
and I think it's amazing if you love
cinema your eyes how hard it is to do
but I have no interest in trying to kind
of relive that or recapture it you know
as a lover of cinema I really just
wanted to try to make an original there
are so many moments from the room that I
think people quote all the time there's
a lot of gifts to that a lot of people
use are there any moments from best
friends that you feel like or maybe fans
have already been saying it's one phrase
you want to say it I will say you can
say [ __ ] a friendship you feel money
friendship before money yeah there is
this a nice phrase you don't think
friendship before money right there is a
scene that Tommy that takes place in his
morgue in which we we honor a Chinese
man that is a scene that I didn't know
the comedy mr. Lee the mr. Lee scene I
didn't know that there was so much
comedy there but we
in London I thought it was a serious
scene and 300 people were laugh through
the entire thing this seems to be the
theme with I thought I was gonna be like
this kind of moving touching scene and
there's so much so I think now I'm
really excited to see the way people
react to that scene Tommy you tweeted
that you are hoping that best friends
will be up for an Academy Award next
year why not what makes it an
oscar-worthy film I be honest with you
always believe in a religion like I've
been friend with Greg for decades and we
always learned about you know
entertainment and I will say always
original staff will be number one
eventually somehow mm-hmm because it's
something special and so pleased that he
actually accomplished that by but doing
everything from scratch and and show the
world like he can do it so I'm very
proud of Greg the same time I probably
give me a job so Tommy I said I think he
I think he should win some type of award
for this whatever it is yeah you need
like a Lifetime Achievement something
somewhere III you know I don't expect
too much but I think he did a good job
and I think people who appreciate if it
would qualify funny oh he's qualified of
the movies qualify why not do it you
know it's just you know it's not a
question to win I said this many time
the question to say hey I'm here you
know maybe you can consider it what is
your take on my project but but I think
it's it's when you go on as a filmmaker
or director or actor to certain level
it's something like you it's for me it's
a happiness you know like either he can
consider to put on certain awards you
know oh thank you yes
[Music]